- [Announcer] Gary V
- By the way, I think I should
only talk in New Jersey.
- [Panelist] I agree.
- Right, fuck it.
(audience clapping)
I'm not sure I want to talk anywhere else
but fucking New Jersey.
I fucking love you guys.
That's some real shit.
I fucking love you guys,
that's some real shit.
That's some real shit.
I just want to be happy.
Don't you want to be happy?
Jersey.
This is super, duper fun for me.
Obviously, I'm at a point in my life
where I get the great luxury of going
around the world and speaking and visiting
all sorts of great places, but to be back
where I grew up feels fucking amazing.
I was doing some photos
and even the people I just
took photos with, it
was just like, I'm like,
this is fucking Jersey.
It's a different flavor and
I'm really excited to be here.
So, let's go right into it.
I want to talk about a
bunch of different stuff.
I've allocated some time for
Q&A so we'll line up for that
at some point but really
what's really interesting,
actually right before,
two seconds before I took
the stage a gentleman grabbed me.
When I spoke in Nashville we
did a consulting session thing
beforehand so I got two
hours with different people
and he just grabbed me and he was like,
"Hey, I just want you to know,
I know you gotta take stage
"right now but I took your
advice and I quit my job
"but I also moved back
to San Diego to do it
"and I decided to pursue
happiness over money."
And it really hit me.
Obviously, when you go on
stage getting something
that feels that nice
right before you go on
between being back home and
hearing something like that,
it's got me in a really
interesting mindset.
We also had a really interesting
drive from my office here
for the last hour with me and my team
just talking about a
lot of different stuff,
stuff that continues to
populate into my mind.
And most of all to be very
frank with everybody here,
when I think about why
would you be here today,
Daymond, me, different
things of that nature,
what made you decide to spend money
and more importantly to be frank,
spend time to decide to come to this?
I think the thing that
has allowed me to have
a successful speaking
career is I'm desperate
and I'm desperate as I
stand up here right now.
I'm desperate to bring the most value
while I'm on stage.
I'm not interested in, listen,
I'm super fucking capable
to get mine without getting
anything from anybody
in this room.
I know what I'm doing
on the business front.
What I'm worried about is
why are you here and how
through the fact that you're actually here
and not watching this on video on YouTube.
From it's just the right moment
based on what happened this week.
To me it's the same game.
The biggest compliment
that I get on social media
is when somebody's trying to dog me
by leaving a comment
of, "Yo fuck this guy.
"He says the same shit."
And I read that and I'm
like, "That's exactly right,
"motherfucker."
(audience clapping)
I have no fucking interest
in making up shit for likes.
I'm gonna say the same shit until the end.
I'm just waiting for you to
be ready to fucking hear it.
My friends, it's uncomfortably
simple out there.
Which means it's ridiculously complicated.
What I mean by that is it's no different.
What I'm gonna talk to you about,
whether it's life or business right now
is really no different than if
this was a health conference.
I would come and they would say,
"How do we get healthier?"
And I would stand up here and I would say,
"I'd like you to eat better
and I'd like you to exercise
every day."
And I would say, "Thank
you very much and I'm out."
That's actually the answer.
But we don't want to hear it.
We'd rather buy $29
fucking apple vinegar shit.
We'd rather buy some fucking thing that
fucking tightens your waist
and performance enhancement drugs
and fucking ass implants
and all this other shit.
The reality is it's super simple.
If for some way through
a joke or an analogy
or a conversation here today
or an answer to a question
I can get you to start
the process of genuinely
being able to handle
judgment because you finally
are exhausted, exhausted
of living your life
based on other people's opinions including
StrangerPants96 and your
mom, those two extremes.
And listen, I know,
how many of you in here
consume my content?
Thank you, so for the ones
that do, you know my example
is the anonymous comment from SallyPants49
or RickFace or JumpMan36,
so it's the two extremes.
It's you don't do things because
somebody says you're ugly
or you're stupid in a
comment and you have no idea
who they are and they're
hiding between an avatar
and some bullshit name over here,
all the way to your mom.
That, that's what I spend all my time on.
From this person to that person,
why is that dictating you?
This one makes a lot of sense to me.
Ironically, that one makes
a lot of sense to me.
You all went through high school.
You all lived life trying to do shit
to impress other people and
we still do it at scale.
The only thing, listen, I'm not out here
living my life trying to
convince people how to make money
like me because making money is a talent,
like singing and playing sports.
Some people are better at it than others.
Can it be taught?
Of course it can be taught.
You can always be better
at something than you were
at a starting point.
I can be better at dancing
and singing and basketball
but I'm not fucking gonna
be Lebron or Beyonce.
Do I think people can go
from the kind of person
that can have a $40
thousand a year business
to a $3 million a year business?
Yes, I do.
Do I think the person
that has the natural skill
of a $40 thousand a year business can make
$45 million a year?
No, I do not.
Do I think that we completely
need to recalibrate
our relationship with
what success looks like?
Yes, I do.
We're out here talking about making
a million dollars a
year as the entry point
to balling when the 1% of
Americans, top earners,
start at $440 thousand a year.
If you make $440 thousand a year in here,
you are in the 1% earners in America.
One of the richest countries in the world.
We're fucking confused, my friends.
There's people here that are
29 that think their life's
fucking over next year
because they're gonna turn 30
and they don't have
their shit figured out.
There's fucking 88-year
olds running around Jersey
that haven't fucking
figured out their life.
I don't know what miraculous
situation of my parents
having sex at the right
moment, me being born
in the Soviet Union,
me growing up in Edison
and working in a liquor
store in Springfield,
but I'm telling you right now
whatever those dynamics were
I sit here back home with an
amazing amount of gratitude
to my perspective.
Forget about anything
else I've got going on.
I'm trying to spend the rest of my life
to articulate my
perspective so that you can
debate it against yours.
I'm not trying to have
you have my perspective.
I'm just trying, I
don't think, by the way,
I don't think I'm right.
I don't think I'm right,
I don't think I've earned
the ability to tell anybody anything.
I think if I disappear tomorrow
in some tragic accident
I'd trend on Twitter for
half a day and then everybody
moves on with their lives.
Like, I get it but I'm telling you,
if you're fucking here
today please hear me.
I can give you every tactic
on LinkedIn and TikTok
and Facebook and email and text.
I can give it to you.
You keep watching what I'm, listen,
you want to have business
success, watch what I do
for the rest of my life
publicly, copy it verbatim
but then put in your shit
in it, and I promise you
you'll be successful.
Because I'm fucking
really good at my shit.
(audience clapping)
That my friends is not
the interesting part.
The interesting part is
why can I do what I do?
Why am I not scared to
make content on TikTok
when it's all teenage people?
Why am I willing to spend a ton of time
having a ton of different shit going on
and if something fails
I don't give a fuck?
I have VaynerMedia, I have
VaynerSports, I have Empathy.
I have a million things going on.
Inevitably some of those
things are gonna fail.
Things that shouldn't
fail but they're going to.
When you have 87 things
you're not gonna go 87 and 0.
My ability to deal with your judgment
when I go 70 and 13 is my strength.
Why are you only doing one thing?
Why don't you do shit?
Because you're fucking scared.
The question is why.
I'm just trying to get to why.
Who, who's gonna cast judgment?
My friends, every person
here that's not 100% happy
including myself is not
doing something because
of judgment of somebody else.
One hundred.
That's the fucking game.
More importantly, how do
you start chipping away
in a world where you were
parented or your environment
made you that way?
How do you chip away?
Here's how.
You story tell.
That is the responsibility
and almost the way
I feel I live.
I have figured out over
the last decade or two,
really actually half-decade to a decade,
oh, I have gift for gab.
Same reason I could sell.
Same reason, oh, I'm a good story teller.
So, I'm gonna give you stories.
Why do I put out those
analogies, those clips
saying the same shit?
Because there's only 15 truths.
I just have to say them
a million different ways
to catch you at the right
time with the right slang
on the right platform at the right moment.
- [Audience Member] Appreciate you, Gary.
- I appreciate you, too.
(audience clapping)
I appreciate you, too.
That's what leads me to
stories like you know how
in high school you were
worried about your zit
and fuck, I used to be scared
as shit when I had a zit.
I was like, "Fuck, I don't
want to go to fucking school."
What I learned through
life was nobody gave a fuck
about my zit.
They were worried about their zit.
The number, why do I tell that story?
Because right now people here are in debt
or can't do something
because they're just staying
above ground, but that's
because they bought a house
that was too expensive, not
using rooms in that house,
and they don't have the
humility to sell that house
and go back to rent
because they don't want
their friend from high
school or their grandma
to judge them because we manifested
that you have to own a home.
And if you did and now you're
not just staying above water
and you sold that home
and moved into a shittier
neighborhood, or a
smaller house, or rented,
now your actual life can open up, but no.
The ideology of owning
a home and the inability
to take a step backwards
to take three steps forward
is gonna make you unhappy until the end.
- [Audience Member] Come on, Gary.
- Yes.
(audience clapping)
From the extreme of
getting somebody in here
this evening to go home and
sell their fucking house
to getting one of you to
not buy a pair of off-whites
that you can't afford,
in those two extremes
are no different than fucking
SallyPants98 to your mom.
This is a game of the edges.
Everybody's focused in the middle.
90%, 95%, 99% of shit you think about
and you consume is in the middle.
So, you don't pay attention to the edges.
It's a fucking game of the edges.
Once you get your relationship down
with the seven fucking people that matter
the most in your life and
actually get to the place
of saying, "I love you but fuck you."
And once you get to that
same relationship over here
which is super simple, "I'm
not sure I even know you
"and fuck you."
That's the game.
Now, don't confuse fuck you.
Let me explain what I mean.
I roll with empathy and
compassion and sympathy.
This isn't fuck you for hate.
This is I'm not willing to live my life
under your judgment of what life is.
Because eventually, let me
tell you the biggest mistake
people make that I've
observed through the millions
of interactions over the
last decade that I consumed.
There are people right now
that are living their life
still in their forties and fifties
based on the opinion of their parents.
They think they're doing the right thing
because the fucking
actually love their parents.
I get it, I love my parents
so uncomfortably much
it scare me.
But they live it because
their appeasing lawyer,
two kids, living in this
area, doing this job.
Don't take risks because
we told you not to.
We came from a generation that didn't.
So, you're doing that.
Or, I was once an entrepreneur.
I fucked it up and so we were scared
so now you don't do that.
They live for their parents.
They think it's good
because everything's good
because you're doing
what your parents want.
You feel like it's good.
And then life keeps going.
And then what starts happening
is they start to resent
their parents because now they're popping
to their 50th birthday,
their 60th birthday,
their 65th birthday.
They get a health scare
and they're like fuck.
I'm not doing what I want to be doing.
My friends, until our society
and this country especially
redefines success in being
happy, not being rich,
everybody will continue
to go down the path
that we're seeing in our
society of depression,
anxiety, drugs.
I believe it the most.
Do I believe that there's
people here that are lucky,
that are talented and love
something and they built
a business that they
actually love that process
and it makes them a lot of wealth?
Yes, I do.
There are, I'm one of them.
I genuinely love my shit.
I love it the most.
Thank God it also manifested
in financial success.
But if you watch my
behavior, you would realize
it's the chase.
When and if the Jets win the Super Bowl
before I buy them, I'm
probably, when and if
the Jets win the Super
Bowl, before I buy them
you're gonna see a video of
61-year old me being fuck.
Now, I gotta buy the Knicks.
What I realized about
me, about why do I love
garage-saleing?
Why have I probably rolled up some people
in this room's house to buy
shit over the last ten years?
It's because I love the hunt.
I wake up at five o'clock in the morning
on a Saturday after
working 90 hours a week
because my hobby is to go to fucking
Oldwick town-wide sale
or fucking Metuchen's
town-wide sale two times a year
to go through people's trash and buy shit
for a dollar that's worth seven,
not because of the dollar and the seven
but because maybe, just
maybe this is the day
that I roll up on somebody's house
and find a rare 1947 Cracker
Jack Green Lantern ring
worth 80 thousand.
And even the 80 thousand
doesn't mean shit.
I get paid more to stand
right here than that.
I just want the fucking hunt.
I want the fucking game.
I want to be the greatest
entrepreneur of all time.
That's I'm giving back so much to you
because I don't think
the greatest entrepreneur
of all time is just the guy or gal that
makes the most money.
I think it's the one that
brings the most value
back to the system and
makes a lot of money.
You could be awesome.
You gotta make, you gotta win both.
That's what I want for you.
Do you know how happy I was
at 27 making $40 thousand
a year living in the Villas
on Springfield Avenue
20 minutes from here?
Fucking working 15 hours a day,
7 fucking days a week, building a business
that wasn't even mine.
Happy as fuck.
While my friends were flossing,
rolling up to my store
in their BMWs that they couldn't afford,
clowning behind my back
that I was carrying out
their case of champagne,
I was fucking plotting.
(audience clapping)
I was in my process.
I was 27, I was 32.
You guys think I'm successful now?
I'm 43, motherfucker.
I haven't even fucking started.
I'm being serious.
I feel the same way right this second
that I did 20 years ago in that store.
I'm plotting, I'm processing.
I'm enjoying my game.
And if I overextend myself and the economy
crashed harder than I thought
and it all goes back to zero
I deserve it.
I love this game so much, even
if it comes to a situation
where I have to pay the
price of playing it wrong.
When we lose an account,
when somebody quits
that I don't want to, when something
investment goes to zero,
I get secretly excited.
You know those weird fucking
movies where there's that scene
where the person gets
punched in the fucking mouth
and you think they're gonna die?
And then they kind of go this
way and then they come back
and look at you, and the
blood's coming down and the shit
and they're just looking at you
and now they're like,
"Oh, now I'm fucking mad."
That's how I live my life.
Every time something bad happens,
I'm more happy than when
something good happens.
Do you know how much I hate
where I'm at right now?
Where now I'm overrated, not underrated?
Anything, if I announce
tomorrow that I'm starting
a candle company, 90%
of people would be like,
"He knows something.
"I'm gonna buy some fucking candles, too."
I'm fucking overrated now
and I fucking hate it.
I might move to China
and get the fuck out.
I like being underrated.
I'm underrated.
I was an immigrant.
I didn't speak English.
I fucking lost my whole life.
That's why I'm winning now.
My friends, this is a fucking game.
You want to fucking win in life?
Fall in love with losing
because most people are here
are scared of it.
I love booing.
You know who my favorite tennis player is?
Novak Djokovic.
You know why?
And I know he's a great player.
If you happened to watch
Wimbledon this year,
you know exactly why.
That whole fucking stadium was rooting
for Roger Federer.
The whole place.
And when that motherfucker beat him,
he ate that grass and what
he was really saying was,
"Fuck you."
I'm on some underdog shit
while people are running around
wearing Lebron and Steph Curry jerseys.
Let me say it one more time
for the kids in the back.
I'm on some underdog
shit while everybody else
is wearing jerseys of
winners to make them feel
like a winner.
(audience clapping)
The number one unlock to
happiness in this room
is to go out there after this talk
and get naked about your vulnerabilities,
what you suck at, take
a step back, go humble.
This is about losing and
humility at the forefront.
And nobody's talking about it.
Every single other person talking
is talking about fake
it until you make it.
Winning at all costs.
Look the part before you are.
It is that shit, my man.
People out here fucking bullshit.
There's people out here acting
like they're entrepreneurs
and their mommy and daddy
are paying for the company.
You ain't winning.
You're fucking losing in a
way that you can't imagine.
Let me tell you about
the world I'm living.
I'm watching people out
here trying to trick losers.
I'm trying to win with winners.
Let me explain.
When your mom and dad are
subsidizing your business
but you're not telling anybody
because you want to look
like you're winning, you're losing because
you're building insecurity.
You're not winning.
The only person you're tricking
is other fucking losers.
My friends, this is real talk.
I'm coming here Jersey
because I'm fucking from here
and I want people to be happy.
Please, please and I mean this.
Especially up there, what's up?
Please, please, please,
please, please do not confuse
the last 15-minute rant with
audacity or bravado or ego.
Please just know that's
my communication style
and reread the words
when you get back home.
This is about love.
I'm trying to get people to win.
I'm watching real deep
sadness and it's not because
of social media.
Social media is not making you sad.
Your insecurity is making you sad.
- [Audience Member] I love you, Gary.
- I love you back.
And that's it, and that's it.
And even winners overextend themselves
raising too much capital
to take it to the next step
and then they get caught
because even with the winning
they still haven't
closed the insecurities.
It's about insecurity.
How did it get there?
And I'm just trying to really put pressure
on this conversation.
I really am.
(exchange in Russian with audience member)
Listen to me, I'm mixing
up Russian and English now.
Listen to me.
(Gary exclaims in Russian)
Fuck, listen, my friends.
I'm serious, this is
super important to me.
It's funny, when I'm in a zone like this
and I felt good all day.
I knew this was gonna go well.
When I'm in a zone like this it's like,
it's hard for me to get excited
to give you the tactics.
It's hard for me to tell you
how to use Instagram stories
or why LinkedIn Organic's on fire
or how you have to get over yourself
and start a TikTok account.
It's the only place that you can get
to a half million followers for free quick
for no reason on some luck
shit by one viral video.
It's hard for me to
get going on that shit.
It's hard for me to get you to understand
that if you literally text every person
in your phone right now and ask for help
and have the humility and
show that vulnerability
good shit can happen.
It's hard for me to give you those things
because you won't do
them if you don't address
the shit I started this talk with.
And the reason that I'm
talking that, my man,
is because I've been
doing this for a minute.
The reason I'm showing
you guys videos of 2009,
bad haircut, fat me, is
because that dude was saying
the same shit I'm saying right now.
There was less eyes on me,
but it's been the same shit.
And it's always gonna be the same shit.
There's no hack.
There's no passive income.
Let me say it one more time.
There's no system.
There's no system that's gonna allow you,
If you're making money,
you gotta watch your money.
What are you gonna lay on
the beach and something's
gonna be, an algorithm and
system are gonna take care of it?
Even fucking when people
do real estate well,
you think that's passive?
Tell people that own real
estate how passive it is
when there's a fucking
leak in the bathroom
or when the maintenance man quits.
Or a tornado takes it out.
What the fuck are you guys talking about?
There's no fucking white
tape thing here with a marker
that I can show you some system.
Zero, there's no system.
You want to build something?
It's hard work and talent.
Hard work and talent.
And by the way, everybody's got talent.
Some kind.
Some talent manifests in
bigger dollars than others.
No doubt.
But honestly, here's the unlock.
Once you stop chasing,
you know how many people
are chasing cryptocurrency,
cannabis, blockchain
because they think there's money there?
And have no idea what the
fuck they're talking about?
I do because I talk to
these fuckers every day.
You ask them one big, "Yo,
I'm a blockchain expert."
You ask them one question,
they're fucking lost.
"Yo, I'm, Gary V, I'm starting that,
"I'm starting a CBD brand."
I'm like, "Good, bro, knock yourself out."
People just talking
bullshit, bullshit, fuck.
Please take my energy here
today because it's on rare form
to get happy.
Just get happy, yo.
Fuck, like fuck.
The biggest confusion in America in 2019
is that money is happiness.
Biggest, and I know what's gonna happen.
It's gonna post on YouTube and
I'm gonna read the comments
and be like, "Yo, easy
for him to say I'm rich,
"but I'll cry in my Ferrari."
Until you're crying in your Ferrari,
you know how many fuckers I
know that cry in their Ferrari?
A lot, because I know a lot of rich people
and they're sad as fuck.
And when you have money
and you're sad as fuck
real bad shit happens.
Because that shit goes
from cognac and weed
to cocaine and guns in your fucking mouth.
My friends, it is time once and for all
to fucking cut the bullshit.
We need to start talking about happiness.
If you're making 37k a year in this room
as a teacher but you
came here to figure out
what business can get
you to a million a year
but you fucking skip home
whistling out of happiness
because your impacting
young people's lives,
then leave this fucking
conference right now
because you fucking won.
You don't need anybody.
- [Audience Member] I love you, Gary.
- I love you so much that
I'm trying to figure out
how to say something in some new way
to get one of you
because you've heard this
so goddamn much from me.
We don't listen because
we don't address the well.
We're all making fancy sinks and wallpaper
and decorating our homes
but it's our foundation,
it's our foundation, it's our foundation.
And that's why I come here guns blazing.
By the way, I think I should
only talk in New Jersey.
- [Panelist] I agree.
- Right?
Fuck it.
(audience clapping)
I'm not sure I want to talk anywhere else
but fucking New Jersey.
I fucking love you guys.
That's some real shit.
That's some real shit,
that's some real shit.
My friends, it's so easy out here.
It's so easy and nobody wants to go there
because you're scared of judgment.
Just listen, the amount
of poison that is sitting
in this room is unheard of.
There is so much hurt in here
and you're scared to put it out.
You want to really get happy?
Go home after this.
Make an Instagram video and talk about
your uncle abusing you,
you stealing money one day,
you selling drugs and
somebody dying that you knew
because of your drugs that you sold them,
the fact that you stole, the
fact that you did bad shit.
Get the poison out of your mouth.
Our poison, if you murdered
somebody don't do it.
You're going to jail.
But for the most part, or just
finally just making a video
and being like, "Yo, I'm scared."
Vulnerability is strength.
You know how many people
in here know they're not
an entrepreneur but it
says it in their bio?
You know why?
Because somehow the shit
that I got made fun of
in the '80s and '90s in this great state
became the cool thing.
My friends, who's over 42 in this room?
Raise your hands.
Tell these youngsters how not
cool entrepreneurship was.
It was if you didn't get good grades
and went to a great school,
that was it unless you were
an athlete or something like that.
But it was like there
was no selling stuff.
But then fucking they made a
movie and Justin Timberlake
said, "You know what's
cooler than a million?
"A billion."
And everybody went off.
That's what happened and
now every, now the fucking,
now the baby wants to hang out with me.
You understand?
This is crazy shit.
This is crazy shit, the
entrepreneur became the cool thing
which immediately means
every 13-year old on Earth
right now wants to be one.
Because quickly at 13 you
realize you have no flow
and you don't run fast so you can't,
you know what's great about
rap and fucking sports
is it's obvious.
If I was one of those
and somebody was like,
people roll up on me all the time,
"Gary, I'm an entrepreneur."
I can't be like, "Show me."
But if somebody's like,
"Yo, Gary, I'm a rapper."
I'm like, "Go."
"Yo, Gary, I'm a basketball player."
I'm like, "Show me."
The reason this entrepreneur
thing is so scary
is you can hide, you can hide.
And what I know is that
there's a lot of people
in this room who are number threes,
who are number sevens,
who are number thirteens
and could be happy.
Let me tell you about entrepreneurship.
If you don't have the
stomach for that shit,
it will eat you up, it will eat you up.
To be a great, great
entrepreneur you actually can't
hear anything because the
second you hear something
you won't take the risks or
make the jumps or the moves
to actually go.
Do you know how many people
are gonna go out of business
in the next two or three years?
Because they don't have
the humility to show people
that they're actually failing currently
so they'd rather completely
go out of business
on some hope shit?
It's real out here, it's real out here.
It's time, listen, every
time I hit the stage
knowing it's being recorded,
I'm like, "Is this gonna be?"
Listen, I've never had really
outside my first one really,
I've never really had a
talk go super, duper, duper,
duper viral.
I've never had a talk
get 100 million views.
And every time I go out
here, I'm like, "Is this
"gonna be the one?"
(audience clapping)
And not because I give a
fuck about 100 million views.
Fuck 100 million views.
Because I want this conversation to go.
As a matter of fact, if
all of you promise me
to take this conversation
and make your own version
of the conversation so that the collective
gets to 100 million and I
get a view, a single view,
I'm good.
I'm gonna get everything by
myself like I always have.
What I want is what I know is happening
in this room right now
which is, this is real.
This is the actual conversation.
And every fucking person in here knows it.
Not everybody loves it, because you know,
if you gotta start thinking about
your actual vulnerabilities,
you know how much we hate
being honest with ourselves?
We love tricking ourselves.
It feels better.
It's not fun to say you suck.
Especially when you put
something on a pedestal.
We've put entrepreneurship on a pedestal
and now everybody wants to be good at it.
I get it.
It's just hard.
Like real hard.
Like really hard.
Guys, let me remind you something.
How many people here have a business?
If you're not annihilating
it right now, you suck.
This is easiest time in
the history of America
to be successful at business.
For everybody that just raised their hand
that isn't annihilating it, you suck.
That's not fun for me to say.
I just really want to make sure.
There's a lot of youngsters in here,
a lot of first-timers even if you're 50.
This is the easiest.
The economy has been
cruising for a decade.
There is so much money in the system.
Of course there's things.
It's easier for white males to get funded.
I understand all that.
I've never gotten funded.
You can start from zero.
Many people start from zero.
If you're not, let me say
this super crystal clear.
If you're not crushing it
right now in your business,
it is highly likely that
you're not good at it.
You might have just started last week
so you haven't had enough time.
On some real shit, because
I know hands are not gonna
want to go up as much right
now, how many people here
have been doing their
business for 3 years?
Raise your hands, raise them high, own it.
I'm telling you.
If it's not crushing, you got a problem.
And that's okay.
There's, I have friends
in Silicon, like in 2006,
that this is when I was
coming up and I was like,
"I don't think you're good."
Shut down their company and
became the seventh employee
at Tumblr and made fucking $12 million.
This is self awareness.
You have to be honest with yourself
because if you're incapable of that
you have no prayer of happiness.
And being honest with yourself is hard.
Being your biggest critic.
Do you know how delusional,
do you know how hard?
My friends, we are so
good at casting judgment
on everybody else.
We're unstoppable at that.
Keyboard warriors on Twitter.
Everyone.
We're not doing that to ourselves.
Now, do not confuse that
with you're grinding
and the company hasn't turned yet
and now you're gonna bail too soon.
Everything is about balance.
Here is my bigger question.
If you're in year six of your company,
after this little rant,
and it's not crushing
but you're happy as fuck, you won.
Take a step back with me and
listen to the last 13 minutes
and let's talk about it one more time.
I come out, we talk about the pressure
on you should be succeeding
because it's easy.
You're not.
You're three years in, you're not.
Now you're feeling like,
"Oh fuck, fuck Gary V."
You know?
But then the twist at the end.
If you fucking love it, let's go.
Let me tell you why I'm
scared and what I want
to push into the system right now.
I believe the following.
I believe that there's
a lot of people here
whose business is unsuccessful
because they're aiming
to make it a $10 million business
and they don't have it in them.
Had they taken a step back and
instead of doing a business
around real estate investing,
or cannabis, or CBD,
or social, or a T-shirt
brand, or whatever the fuck,
if they took a step back and said, "Okay."
Because everybody comes in hot.
Every kid that starts a T-shirt brand
rolls into my office or my DM and is like,
"Yo, I'm about to build the next Supreme."
I'm like, "No, you're not."
Anybody who's gonna build the next Supreme
doesn't tell somebody they're
building the next Supreme.
They tell themselves.
But if you took a step
back and actually said,
"What do I fucking like?"
What do you like?
What are you about?
What are your interests?
What do you like?
How do you take a step back
and focus on what you like
and then build a practical
business around that?
I so believe in that shit.
Now, that business might
be $84 thousand a year.
If you like Smurfs and you
start a fucking Smurf podcast
and sell Smurf hoodies I do
not believe that business
is gonna do $8.3 million a year.
My question is which one is better?
Is it better to be happy, hit on a number
and live within those
means or is it better
to listen to macro trends,
shit that you don't want,
chase the money and make
yourself vulnerable and unhappy?
That's the big, and by the way.
There's a lot of people
who have the great fortune
of loving something that
allows them to make dollars.
There's a lot of people
who just love the process
of business.
I'm one of them.
I can love anything.
Nothing, whether it's garage
sale or selling services
or wine, if my dad had a
tire store I would have built
the biggest fucking
tire store in the world.
Some people just like
that and that's fine, too,
but honestly this is one,
enormous game of self awareness.
Enormous, around really
getting into your skills.
The skills can be taught, my friends.
Google and YouTube will
teach you everything.
What do you want to know?
Google and YouTube will teach it to you.
Do you want the tactics?
You want to build a website with a funnel
that creates a subscription business?
Free, Google, YouTube.
Google, YouTube.
This is not about Google, YouTube.
This is not about the tactics.
This is about the structure, the strategy,
the self awareness, the
mindset, and really taking
this conversation deeper to
really know what you're about
and how you got here.
To change up your shit,
you have to do new shit.
There is so many people
here on year 20 of trying
to figure it out to get
there, but they've been doing
the same thing in different ways.
Just listening to a different
voice, a different e-book,
a different seminar, but
doing the same hustle
with a different disguise.
You want new shit?
You gotta do new shit.
You gotta try something different.
I'm proposing an alternative to the masses
of what I see out there.
Patience, you know why I push it?
You can't build anything
meaningful in a fucking year.
It's why people buy lottery tickets.
It's not gonna work.
- [Audience Member] Thank you.
- You're welcome.
I'm done, let's do Q&A.
Thank you!
(audience clapping)
I think we're doing Q&A.
Right there and I think
there's, you're the line.
Is there another line?
I don't know.
- [Helper] On the other side.
- Okay, let's start over here.
Are we doing double mics, you think?
- [Helper] This works, this works.
You can do it starting here.
- All right, let's get right into it.
Now we get into the good part.
Go ahead, my man.
- [Questioner] Hey Gary,
so my partner and I
- Shh shh.
- [Questioner] Scaled our business
- What's that brother?
- My partner scaled our
business, my partner and I
from zero to 350 in the first ten months.
- 350?
- [Questioner] K, sorry, we projected 500
- I mean, I was getting excited.
In the first six months?
- Ten months until right now.
- [Gary] Ten months, doing
what, selling, doing what?
- Apparel.
- [Gary] Apparel.
- And so it's, I can't really
say the most legitimate
thing and we need to have
someone to acquire it.
Now, we've had someone offer it.
The thing though is they
want us to be a consultant,
like a marketing consultant,
social media consultant,
just a consultant for the
whole business for everything.
And we're trying to
figure out how the fuck
we leverage our assets,
like our Facebook Pixel,
and just our knowledge,
because we're both really green
into the market still.
- [Gary] Why do you want to sell it?
- Because we need a lot of licensing
and a lot of stuff, yeah.
- [Gary] I see, you don't feel strong
about how you have it.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] Like if it gets too
big it actually goes to zero?
- Yeah, basically.
- [Gary] So then sell it.
So, why overthink the other variables?
- We're gonna be in their team as well,
so we're help some on the business
and then we're gonna
help in other businesses.
Besides the whole
logistics with the business
we're gonna sell it for the mentorship
and just to learn.
- [Gary] I understand,
because you're young.
- Because just in the long run, exactly.
- [Gary] Okay, so?
- But then how do we
leverage being a consultant?
Because there's really no
mathematical number there
to determine how much.
- You're not leveraging the consultancy.
- [Questioner] Well not
leveraging, that's a bad word.
I'm sorry.
- Have you maximized it?
- [Questioner] Yes.
- Ask for more money.
- [Questioner] Okay.
- Like, literally no joke
and I, now I understand
what you're saying.
So, you're trying to figure
out, there's a multiple
against the 350 and then
you're trying to figure out
how much should we get for the consulting?
- [Questioner] Yes.
- Over the two-year period,
the three-year period
or whatever the contract states?
- [Questioner] Exactly.
- This is for everybody.
Always ask for the craziest number
that you think is possible.
- [Questioner] Okay.
- Now, I don't think you should
ask for ten million a year.
That doesn't make logical sense.
Whatever number you have
in your mind per year,
double it.
- [Questioner] Okay.
- That.
- [Questioner] All right.
- Good.
- [Questioner] Thank you.
- You're welcome.
Mike, yep, go ahead, go ahead.
- [Michael] What was your first business?
- My first business was
20 minutes from here
on Tingley Lane in Edison, New Jersey.
I was, just turned six and
I would go to people's yards
and I would rip their
flowers out of their yard
and I would ring their doorbell
and I would sell it back to them.
Now, Michael, a couple things
because I have to shoot
it straight up here.
I'm not necessarily proud of that
and when you look cute like you do now
and I did then, you could
get away with that shit,
but that shit goes away quick.
That's like a crime.
So, make sure you don't
fuck up, okay, bro?
- [Questioner] What's up, buddy?
- Good to see you.
- [Questioner] So, before I say anything,
you see that number on his hoodie?
That changed my life, so I highly suggest
that all of you text that
number right fucking now
because I'm interning for Gary next summer
and because literally my
last week of my internship
last summer I texted him,
"Hey, can I intern for you?"
And he said, "Sure, email D-Rock."
Access, access, that number
right there is access.
- [Gary] It's true.
- [Questioner] So, I just
want to start off with that.
And I actually did have a question,
because I know we had a seven
minute conversation before.
So, in terms of with everything,
with the Relay for Life
and everything, I was passing
it off to my roommate there,
Brian, and this is a
little higher level stuff
that you'll definitely understand.
Passing something off that's your baby
- Is devastating.
- It shook my whole
structure and everything.
- [Gary] Can I give you a very
easy answer because I want
to get to a lot of them?
When you pass something,
you've made the decision
to not be in control.
The end.
- [Spokesperson] Podcast is
People Who Make Things Happen
at official name there
on the screen, thank you.
- What he's referring to
is when I left Wine Library
it was really hard for
me to watch what my dad
did with it.
That's real.
But I left.
Once you give up the wheel, you don't get
to pass judgment and
people struggle with that.
If you want to control it,
get back in the fucking seat.
- [Questioner] Hi, oh, okay.
Hi, Gary.
- [Gary] Hi.
- Also immigrant from Belarus.
- [Gary] Awesome.
- I came here nine years ago,
just like a little back story
with nothing, not knowing anybody.
I didn't speak English.
No papers, none of that.
So, because of that in
the meantime I tried
a hundred things possible
to hustle and survive.
- [Gary] Of course.
- I fell in love with some.
Loved some of them and hated the least,
but inevitably even things
that I love the most,
I kind of lost interest, so for me like
- [Gary] Because you didn't love them.
- I did though.
- [Gary] No, you didn't.
You hooked up with them.
(audience laughing and clapping)
Honestly, it's really cool.
I'm glad we're having this convo.
You think you loved them, but you didn't.
You liked them for a period of time.
You never stop the thing
you love, I promise you.
What I'm doing right this second,
I will do to my last breath.
- [Questioner] What if
I don't have something
like that and I already tried?
I think everything I've possible under
- [Gary] You're smart enough
to know you have not tried
everything possible that
you have, thank you.
- [Questioner] Hey Gary, thanks.
I'm 42 years old.
When I was in tenth grade
I wanted to be a barber
more than anything.
Everyone told me it
wasn't gonna be a thing.
I went to school.
My mom signed me up.
She then enrolled with
me, really embarrassing.
The newspaper came in and asked me,
"What do you want to do?"
I said there were no
barber schools in town.
I had to go to cosmetology
and cut women's hair,
which helped me a lot in my career.
- [Gary] I'm sure.
- And they asked me what I wanted to do
and I said, "One day I
want to open up a school."
I've been doing everything that I've said
I was gonna do since I was in tenth grade.
I wanted to be a singer first,
but I fell in love with hair
and creativity.
I'm the only owner of the most successful
barber school in Philadelphia.
- [Gary] I love it.
(audience clapping)
I don't say that in arrogance.
- [Gary] I get it.
- I started with $300
from my first barber shop.
I know the grind, I know
the mud, I know the dirt.
I do a live feed every Tuesday, 9:30 a.m.
I only have 58 thousand followers.
I get 200 something
- [Gary] That's about 58
thousand more then most people.
- Oh, absolutely, I understand.
I'm saying I get 200 views of watching
my live content every Tuesday.
- [Gary] Love it.
- I haven't been able to grow Instagram
- [Gary] I see.
- And get past that
but not just Instagram.
My business for my school,
90/10, less than 90%
of my income comes from
government funding.
10% or more has to come from cash business
or whatever, self pay,
military aid, whatever.
I want to flip it and get from 10 to 90
and not have to rely on the government
because if the government
says that my students
- [Gary] Yes, you're
vulnerable, you're vulnerable.
- Can't come to school, I want
to get out of vulnerability.
- [Gary] So, don't, so
let's go, meaning less.
- That's what I'd like
to do, so my question is
how do I get to that point?
Because I've been putting in the work.
We put out content every single day.
- [Gary] Do you run ads?
- Absolutely.
- [Gary] How much?
- I mean, every day
we're putting stuff out,
every single day.
- [Gary] How much?
- When you say, "How
much?" what do you mean?
Oh money, we do $5 thousand.
- [Gary] Tell me the truth
because I want you to win.
- $5 thousand on Facebook ads a month,
okay, but we're doing
Instagram, Push notifications,
Push ads, I don't know the exact number.
- [Gary] No, and stories.
- Absolutely, absolutely,
Swipe Up, all that, My Page.
- [Gary] How's it doing?
- It's doing well, I'm
getting a lot of engagement.
I'm getting a lot of engagement
and we're getting
enrollments without paying
for ads like, when I'm talking
about ads, I'm talking about
- You're talking about
scaling and that's where
I'm playing with you on this.
You need to make, if
you're spending $5 thousand
a month, you need to make
the CAC and the LTV work.
CAC, Customer Acquisition Cost.
LTV, Life Time Value.
You want to get off?
The way you do is actually
build a humongous business.
The way you do that is you
find a channel in the world,
direct mail, commercials,
print ads, then Google AdWords,
then email, then social, right?
You find a place where, if
you're putting $5 thousand
into the system, my question
is how much enrollment
from Facebook?
- So, we get about eight
to ten students enrollment
per month.
We already have 12 on the
list, on the waiting list
right now without doing Google
ads and an amazing website.
Just from social.
- [Gary] Okay.
- Just from social, that's it.
So, that's $17 thousand per
student to go to our program.
- [Gary] And how much profit
do you make against that?
- So, we're not in the red anymore.
I mean, currently my
business is worth 2.5,
somewhere close to that
the last time I checked.
- You mean by multiple
of top line revenue?
- I mean, we're not in the red.
We're green, we're doing
well, but I'm afraid
that if we lose government
aid that could affect
our business tremendously.
- [Gary] No, it will.
- And we're changing people's lives.
That's the thing, I'm
creating so much value.
- [Gary] You have to run
ads against your profit
to convert better return on the ad spend.
- Okay.
- I also think you need to
go heavy organic TikTok.
- [Questioner] Okay.
- I mean it.
- [Questioner] I gotcha.
- I, you know, everyone's gonna regret.
This is the fucking same show
I've been living my whole life.
I did this about YouTube
and Instagram, whatever.
- [Questioner] TikTok.
- TikTok.
- [Questioner] Got it, one more thing.
- Yes.
- [Questioner] I want to come on the show
and if you say no, it's okay.
- No.
- [Questioner] I get it.
- [Questioner] I'm gonna do the GSX.
- Okay.
- It's expensive as fuck.
- [Questioner] I gotcha, I'm
gonna look at it, however
- Don't do it, don't do it.
I don't like where your
economics are, don't do it.
- [Questioner] It's okay,
here's what I'm saying.
I want to know how and when
if no is the answer today.
- Keep asking different ways.
- [Questioner] You got it, thank you.
- [Questioner] Hey Gary
V, my name is Bobby Jones
and my question, I'm
gonna try to make it quick
but it's got a little bit of a back story.
So, I grew up foster care,
got into a ton of trouble
as soon as I was old enough to.
I actually went to jail
and numerous times.
My daughter was born while I was in there
and I got to a point where I was almost
gonna do life in prison.
I got miraculously saved,
came home, busted my ass,
got a nine to five.
As soon as the nine to five
ceiling presented itself
I started my own business.
My business has grown 49%
over the last three years
and I've gotten to a
point where it pretty much
runs itself and I've gotten
a lot of my time back.
I'm really happy with where it is
and I've been able to do
a lot with youth justice,
at-risk youth.
Going back and speaking
to detention centers
and different schools
and alternative programs.
(audience clapping)
Thank you, thank you.
And I really, really love doing that.
And I get a ton of feedback
and I've been asked
to do more and more.
- [Gary] Go ahead.
- But my question is, at
what point, because I could
probably keep with my business
and grow it to ten million
and really have a better
platform to explore that more,
but I don't love it the
way that I love doing
these discussions and
speaking and helping.
- [Gary] Push hard from both sides.
Where's it at right now?
- [Questioner] It's at three million.
- Great, how I hear it
if I was your brother,
I'd be like, "Yo, bro,
okay, so three to ten
is full pot committed
and here's the talking.
Let's take it from three
to six and do both."
- [Questioner] Yes, sir.
- The answer to so many questions is both.
You just gotta cut out dumb shit.
- [Questioner] I'm also doing
some real estate investing
and another business as
well, so it's gonna get
to that point.
All right, thank you, man.
- You got it, brother.
- [Questioner] Hey, Gary.
- How are you?
- [Questioner] I'm great, how are you?
- I'm well.
- [Questioner] My dad's name
was Gary, passed last year.
- I'm sorry to hear that.
- [Questioner] So, love,
you've been that love.
My name is Drew Berman from DrewBerman.com
and my book just came out.
I'm proud of it.
- [Gary] Congrats.
- Thank so much, thank you, so it's called
"You Can Have It All"
and I studied marketing
in college and I ended up
picking the profession network marketing.
So, I've been in network
marketing for 17 years
and I never dabbled with it.
I never took it part time and I ended up
making a career out of it.
But your talk was pretty powerful because
there's a lot of people who
wear a network marketing hat
and don't even have a
clue about networking
or marketing or network marketing
or what it means to own a business.
And it tends to be a fall in
your lap type of business.
People fall into it because they find
a product that they like
or they find a friend
that introduces them.
And a lot of people, a
lot, thousands, Gary,
hundreds of thousands are clueless.
- [Gary] Okay, so what's it teach you?
- The book teaches people
how to do it right.
- [Gary] Understood.
- And it's
- [Gary] That's a commercial,
what's the question?
- The question is it's an
industry that's completely
on its vertical upswing
and I feel this can help
a lot of people, so I'm building platforms
on all of the platforms and
I get, you know, whatever.
You're mentioning TikTok.
If you were doing that,
if you were gonna launch
to that particular industry,
how would you brand yourself?
How would you brand a brand new book?
- I think it's all about
communicating contextual
to the platform.
So, the way I think about
branding is communicating,
telling your truth but then
respecting the algorithms
and the features and the
mindset of the people
consuming it on the other side.
Everybody here is actually
a different person
when they're in their Instagram feed
versus when they're in
their Pinterest board
versus when they're on LinkedIn.
This is a mindset, context, content game,
not just a content and
blast all platforms.
That's what I would do.
- [Questioner] Can I gift you my book?
- Of course, happy to do it.
Let's go, hi, thank you.
- [Questioner] First I want to say.
- Thank you.
- - [Questioner] You're the shit.
I binge watch you before I go to sleep,
so I am all up in your
face before I go to bed.
My name is Meg.
I started my hair, Curly Hair Alchemist.
- [Greg] Love it.
- I just went digital, so I have a salon.
I've been open, I've
had a brick and mortar
for a year, but I've
been open under myself
for three years.
I do about 16 hundred services a year,
so that means I touch 16
hundred people's heads.
I'm the top stylist.
I plan on hiring people next year.
I don't know how to do
that or figure it out.
- [Greg] Can I give you
a quick one on that?
- Please.
- Don't overthink it.
Tell them the truth and
when they don't deliver
on the truth, fire them.
People struggle with scaling.
Shit like you're doing.
Just people overthink it and they have ego
that I'm the only one that does it best
and then nobody's ever good enough.
Go within humility, tell them the truth
- [Questioner] Got you.
- And then if they don't
deliver on it, fire.
I've watched so many people
that are great at their craft
never build a business because of ego
that they like feeling that they're better
at this thing than anybody than
actually scaling a business.
- [Questioner] Okay, got you.
- Go ahead.
- [Questioner] I just went digital.
I'm launching my online
course on November 1st
called "Curls Hold Magic Blueprint".
I pre-sold for $77.33.
I have 49 members in my program.
I don't know what the fuck I'm doing.
- [Gary] That's bad.
- So, what's happening is
when I'm, I have a plan
on how to engage.
I feel like what I do behind
the chair is very valuable.
I touch people's hearts.
I send them home, they feel beautiful.
- [Gary] Love it.
- Right, how can I do that digitally
and piggy-backing off that, how do
- By talking to them.
- [Questioner] Yes, right, but I mean.
- No, no.
- [Questioner] No, I understand.
No, I'm very vulnerable
on camera with them.
What do you mean?
- Well then, write.
- [Questioner] Write.
- Don't go on camera.
- [Questioner] Just write it?
- Yeah.
- Oh, I'm bad at writing.
- [Gary] Okay, stick with me.
- Okay.
- [Gary] Then record the
memo and send it to them.
- [Questioner] Okay.
- You're a communicator.
- [Questioner] Oh, so my mouth, yeah.
- Well, if you get, some people freeze
when the camera is the addition, however
you have gift of gab in just audio,
so just do a memo and blast it to them.
- [Questioner] Got you, okay.
- It's about communication.
- [Questioner] All right, because I'm not
behind the chair I feel insecure
about being digital.
- [Gary] Record the memo
when you're behind the chair.
- Yeah that's just keep constant, right?
All right, I'll get
back to you, thank you.
(audience clapping)
- [Questioner] Hi.
- Hi.
- [Questioner] Hi, I just
wanted to say thank you
for you honesty and transparency.
- Thank you.
- [Questioner] But I'm from
Charlottesville, Virginia
and I became a brand
ambassador for a non-profit
called Soles for Souls.
They focused on wearing out poverty
by redistributing shoes.
So, three months ago I
launched a shoe drive.
I'm collecting 25 thousand pairs.
I'm at about 25 hundred
and I just wanted to see
if you'd be willing to ask
K-Swiss if they could donate?
- [Greg] Yes.
- Thank you.
You got it, Dana?
Just email me right now and say,
"I'm the lady from Virginia that asked
"for the K-Swiss stuff."
- [Questioner] Thank you.
- I will hook it up.
(audience clapping)
- [Questioner] How you doing, Gary?
- And by the way, if they don't, I will.
- [Questioner] Hi, Gary,
just want to say thank you
personally.
- [Gary] Thank you.
- Just to tell you very
quickly, a lot of people
would consider what I
do daily for a career
successful on paper and
you have fully convinced me
to do what I'm passionate
about and do what I love
and I'm officially
making this my last year
doing that to move towards what I want,
so thank you for that.
- And listen, listen, this
is such an important part
of this conversation
because I'm scared shitless
of people quitting shit.
- [Questioner] Oh, I'm
quitting, I'm quitting.
- Going on some fantasy journey and then
I'm the fucker that fucked them up.
So, let me go real quick with this.
Here's why I'm passionate about it.
You're so young that you're
not gonna have to live
with regret that you didn't try
because when and if you
fail at whatever you're
about to do, you can
always go back to this.
You can always go back to
the thing you don't love.
- [Questioner] I won't but
thank you, yes, thank you.
It's true, so my question is my team and I
have been forming a finance consultancy
for solar dealers and
we're currently based
out of Pennsylvania.
What we intend to do is try to grow this
to a national scale eventually.
And right now my question
is do I start engaging
with clients in a smaller
market like Pennsylvania
or move to a bigger
market like California?
- Do you want to move to California?
- [Questioner] I would move
anywhere to make this happen.
- Do you think it's too
competitive in California?
- [Questioner] Based on what the market is
for what we're providing
as our services, no.
- [Greg] Then you should go to California.
- Done, thank you.
(audience clapping)
- A few more minutes, a few more minutes.
- [Questioner] Hi Gary.
- How are you?
- [Questioner] I'm good.
I wanted to say I've been DM-ing you since
February 2017.
- [Gary] Geez.
- And I suck, but I've been grinding.
- [Gary] Respect.
- So
- [Gary] And your shoes are fly as fuck.
- Oh, thank you, thank you, thank you.
So, I'm a 52-year old mother of four
and I have a luxury
clothing brand called Harx4,
and that's H-A-R-X-4
and I recently just did
last season of Project Runway.
- [Greg] Wow.
- And, thank you.
And now I'm at a point
where I'm rebranding
because I lost a whole lot of money.
- [Gary] Why?
- And I don't have any money.
- [Gary] Why'd you lose it?
- Because I was doing things.
- [Gary] Dumb shit.
- Exactly, I was putting
the cart before the horse.
I'm doing New York Fashion Week
and I can't even produce a product.
- [Gary] Impatience, girl.
- Exactly, so now, everyone
talks about content,
so I'm trying to determine
do I tell a story?
- [Gary] Yep.
- Or do I build mediocre content
meaning editorial content?
- Why is it mediocre?
- [Questioner] Because
I have a luxury brand
and I can't compete with the
people that I'm on the racks
with next to in Saks if I don't have
a product that's competing.
- [Gary] Why do you assume
that the content has to be
high production value to
be considered quality?
- Because what I see in
magazines and the newspapers
that people making money.
- Stop, stop, you're looking backwards.
You're looking backwards.
You know this.
Do you think a 52-year old
woman would look as fly as you
20 years ago?
- [Questioner] No.
- Correct, stick with me.
We've all changed.
The gentleman, the barber, 42.
I'm looking at him like
for everybody over 40,
all of us, we know, you know
exactly where I'm taking this.
The youthification, millionaires
did not look like this
20 years ago.
I'd have a dumb ass suit.
42, 50, look at you, you look 18.
- [Questioner] Thank you.
- No, no, I'm trying to make a point here.
I'm telling you right
now, that high glossy
fucking photo shoot that you can't afford
to be in fucking Vogue doesn't
work the same way anymore.
Just like 50, do you
understand what I'm saying?
- [Questioner] Yes, yes, yes.
- So, stop making judgment on the past
and start being practical
of what you can do
instead of dwelling on what you can't do.
- Okay, will do, and thank you.
And look at, look for my DM, Harx4.
- [Gary] I'll look for it.
- [Questioner] Hi.
- All right, last one.
I'm sorry.
Go ahead, I'm so sorry, I know.
Fuck, bro, what do you want?
I got a charity event I gotta go to.
You don't like charity?
Let's go, go ahead.
- [Jennifer] My name is Jennifer Perry.
- Hi Jennifer.
- [Jennifer] I'm the CEO
of SacredSeedsForYou.com,
a natural skin care company.
Though I had been doing it on the side
for 20 years, I left my job.
I lost three friends back to back to back.
- [Gary] That passed?
- Died, Edwards died.
Four days later Combat Jack Reggio.
- [Gary] I'm sorry.
- [Jennifer] Say, two
weeks later another friend.
So, I went to my job and I quit.
I didn't have the nest egg.
I didn't have it prepared.
- [Gary] Yo, everybody
leaving, I love you, see ya.
- It was the whole leap
and the net will appear.
But that puts me in a position where
I'm burning the candle at a lot of ends.
- [Gary] Of course, of course.
- I'm a sole entrepreneur.
I just had a Reiki person talk to me
and she knew about the chest pains
- [Gary] I get it.
- That I was having.
So, I don't want the burn out,
but there's a lot that I want to do,
a lot that I'm trying to reach.
And with the natural skin care baskets
- [Gary] I get it.
- I've donated to homeless shelters.
- [Gary] I got it.
- Victims of domestic violence.
- [Gary] So, what's the question?
- [Jennifer] So, how
can I avoid the burn out
and then how can I have you
help me donate to more people
to the homeless, to the
people in the inner city
to get Edward's book out,
to get the product out?
- I don't want to bullshit you
and make promises I can't deliver,
so I don't know.
You'll have to send me an email to Gary V.
I gotta understand what the fuck
you're actually asking
for and talking about.
As far as burning from both sides,
you can readjust.
People burn out because
they need something
to happen faster.
Put yourself in a position
to let it happen slower.
You gotta think about your expenses.
You gotta think, there's only two things.
Either you can't afford to keep doing it
or you want it to get big too fast.
Got it?
Look at both.
The one that you can't
afford you gotta change
your expenses.
Whatever that may be.
Home, travel, the cost of goods.
Or if you want it too
fast you have to flip
your framework and realize
you're still young.
You can get to it.
You got fucking 40
years to actually do it.
Not four months, even
though we've lived a little.
You understand?
- [Jennifer] Yeah, it's
just the fragility is life
and you keep burying
people like that, you know?
- But you can't boil the ocean.
Everybody out here is trying to change.
Everybody here is trying
to change the world.
Change yourself first.
I love you, Jers.
(audience clapping)
I see you up there.
Thank you so much, thank you so much.